we're gonna get out of Mark Steyn who's
been watching this unfold mark you there
yes I am Duggar
what do you what do you make of this I
mean this is not if you had to make a
list of predictions two years ago this
would not be on it I assume no but
President Trump does things differently
this is a kind of upside-down summit in
a way it's going to start with him and
came just in the room together with no
one but translators that's really the
opposite of the way almost any
international gathering takes place you
know the term I think Churchill coined
it Sherpas the people who map out
everything the summits going to agree
and then when eighty-eight percent has
been set in stone then the leaders come
in and and basically put the their
imprimatur on this this is completely
the opposite Donald Trump is going to
walk into that room and he's going to
make his own calculation as to whether
Kim jong-un is there in good faith and
it's basically going to be the president
who calls it and decides whether or not
this process is sincere and it's for
real and that's very different from the
way almost any other international
symmetry takes place in the modern world
what do you make of this that is that by
the way we're watching now the
president's motorcade in Singapore going
to the summit site what do you make it
the way this this came about I mean I
don't think was anyone who predicted
this and it came out of the president's
kind of signature bellicosity which
supposedly gets you nothing but in this
case did get us something yeah and I
actually think that's one of the the the
most effective things you know the
weakness of the Western world generally
is that when we enter into talks or
talks about talks these third-world
dictators always understand that our
priority is to be in a room sitting down
talking and getting an agreement and
we'll do almost anything to get into
and chit-chatting and having tea and
coffee and cookies
with the third world dictator the
Iranians understood that for example in
their negotiations for years with with
Europe and then with the Obama
administration and this is the complete
opposite Trump's signature style was
basically to go metaphorically nuclear
on the Pyongyang regime and then when it
was clear that he wasn't like Obama and
other Western leaders to offer the
carrot of negotiation and then just when
you know Kim was getting cocky and he
decided to start trashing Mike Pence and
John Bolton and all the rest of it at
that point
Trump yank the rug out from under him so
this is a very different style in in a
sense the the house-trained Western
leader is behaving as unpredictably as
the the third-world basket-case guy and
that's a completely different style of
negotiation whose motorcade by the way
we're just watching pass by we saw it a
second ago they're heading to Sentosa
which apparently is Sanskrit for peace
there it is right there this is a man
who does not leave his country very
often I think since returning home from
boarding school in Switzerland he's left
only a couple of times once recently in
China by armored train kind of
remarkable that he's left North Korea to
come to Singapore for this what do you
suppose he hopes to get out of it well
you know I thought it was very
interesting when he was touring that
casino last night he's actually getting
a glimpse of what almost every I mean
Singapore spectacularly successful has
won the highest GDP per capita in the
world if you're an old-school
imperialist like me you think that's all
down to sustain food raffles and if
you're of more recent visitors you think
it was Lee Kuan Yew who's done it since
1963 but whoever you give it credit to
Singapore is a hugely successful society
and so when a dictator of a basket case
of a country with barely detectable GDP
that makes nothing that anybody needs
except cheap knockoff viagra and which I
hope performs rather better than their
nuclear weapons do but that guy is
getting a glimpse of how of how modern
societies work and and the invitation to
him really is to say we'll overlook the
fact that you killed all these people
you've starved all these people and the
carrot for you is that your society
could be like every other society in
that corner of the world it could be
hugely successful and you would live
better because even dictators live badly
in dysfunctional society that's right
you know the electrical supply in the
presidential palace in Pyongyang isn't
more reliable than the electrical supply
anywhere else what do you think he
thinks when he lands in a Chinese 747 in
Singapore and looks around do you think
it shakes his faith in the Marxism he
professes to believe in
I don't know that he'd this is the
interesting question I don't think this
guy is a madman and I don't think
hereditary dictatorships survived over
three generations without having a
strong sense of self-preservation but
the self-preservation is is more
important than any ideological
commitment I mean basically Marxism as
Karl Marx developed it in the 19th
century was supposed to improve the
lives of the proletariat in the modern
era for people like him it's the way of
controlling the proletariat you can't
control them if you have a free market
society in which people are allowed to
live lives that fulfil their potential
so he's not a Marxist he's not a Marxist
in the sense of an economic theory he's
a communist dictator because that's
that's the way you control
people and that's all it is and when
he's looking at when he's looking at
Singapore the question is whether he can
make the leap of imagination he doesn't
to look that fyke and look at South
Korea but he's actually walking around
in what a functioning society looks like
that's what he was doing last night and
that that for him is a first it's not
like you know it's it's it's different
from Switzerland because it's closer to
home and they did it in even less time
now as I said I I think singer boys a
lot to do with Stamford Raffles and all
that but if you happen to think it's all
to do with Lee Kuan Yew Lee did that in
less time he's done it in what is it now
fifty five years so he's actually built
that society built modern Singapore in
less time than the Kim's have driven
North Korea because they've been running
that now for an extra whatever it is ten
ten years on that they've actually
driven that joint into the ground this
is what you can do if you're actually
building a society the first thing the
Lee Kuan Yew did was eliminate
corruption though oh it's my feet
stumbling block for the Kim regime
that's true mark will you stay with us
we're going to be enrolling coverage for
the next hour if you would